writing a book is not about just writing
the book that was that was difficult
enough for me the hard part now is with
this promotion I came up with a Times
Square billboard because I assume you're
gonna have a Time Square boy okay assume
anything but go ahead I have a concept
for it that I brought in to show you can
tell me you've got visual aids oh boy
will you actually like try and have an
open mind about this now just
immediately [ __ ] on it Robin can you see
your ideas Wow okay you know when you
see it when you see it at first you
might think oh what's so great about
that shall we - okay imagine this like
20 floors high in Times Square right
okay so this is what its gonna look like
[Music]
this is a billboard it's a billboard
it's imaginary you're lying in bed naked
you got to see this you're jerking off
and you're smiling you're smiling I
usually lose a bet no I swear to God how
many billboards have you seen in Times
Square of a guy jerking off are you
[ __ ] implied jerking off because you
can't see your hand in the book they're
not gonna put that up in [ __ ] how are
you not keep in mind
I was excited about the point is like
now you're this like evolved family so I
put the picture of your like cat Walter
you got Beth watching you jerking off
and then like your blind cat is in bed
with you while you're jerking off you
have the book covering your junk so no
one's offended and you have a big smile
day I had an interaction with you in
here yeah I was so impressed I was like
you know this [ __ ] guy is counted yes
I don't know if you're for real or not
this is the same thing you did with the
Superbowl commercial like yes a
billboard of my book would be fabulous
in Time Square now think about it I want
to reach the people yes just listen to
me I want to reach people who maybe
don't realize this is a really good book
in my opinion like something really
really really meaty and really good to
read about how this is evolution yeah
I'm trying to reach people who maybe are
turned off to me they see a picture of
me in bed Jirga is provided that even in
Times Square the guy who owns the
billboard is willing to put a guy
jerking off in the billboard what you're
looking at yes Mike dreamer like do you
remember how Dave Letterman used to like
squirt water on people as they walk this
is the surprise people are in Times
Square yes right like families and every
hour on the hour it'll just be like Oh
[Laughter]
at least you save the best part I'm with
my med on this that's [ __ ] coming
minute [ __ ] turns into this MIT has
like facial recognition technology so
now you're being so a guy coming on come
it's just shaving cream yeah but but you
don't understand coming out of his day
his implied dick book that's covering
your job come every hour in times all
right okay I gotta get out of this
country
I gotta get out of this conversation